- [Narrator] In January
2020, say an Uber ride
from New York City's
John F. Kennedy Airport
to Midtown Manhattan cost about $50.
Today, based on the average
price rise of Uber rides,
that same trip could be $75,
about a 50% jump.
You may have noticed this too.
According to data from
Rakuten Intelligence,
the average Uber and Lyft
fair in the US rose month
to month from February through July,
breaking records each time.
In July 2021, consumers
paid over 50% more per ride
compared with January 2020.
- All these customers are complaining
that they are actually
paying more for their ride.
- [Narrator] The biggest
factor that's driving prices up
has to do with the pandemic,
but prices were slowly beginning to rise
even before the pandemic.
- To all the viewers seeing this,
don't expect dirt cheap prices the way
that we had before the pandemic.
- [Narrator] Here's why
your Uber and Lyft rides
are going through the roof,
and why they might not ever come
all the way back down
to where they once were.
- Ride prices are higher
for customers right now,
especially during the pandemic
'cause there is that shortage of drivers
and increased demand.
- [Narrator] Harry Campbell,
an Uber and Lyft driver
runs a popular blog called Rideshare Guy.
- Drivers, like many others,
had a huge impact by the pandemic,
and I think really what
we saw at the start
was demand for ride hail
really just fell off the cliff.
- [Narrator] In early 2020,
bookings for Uber rides declined 75%
as Americans hunkered
down for the pandemic.
As states have opened back up,
the demand for rides has returned faster
than the supply of drivers,
resulting in price hikes in many cities
across the US.
Experts say that prices are taking a while
to return to normal for a few reasons.
- I think the number one factor
why drivers haven't come
back to Uber and Lyft,
and why we're seeing this shortage
on the supply side still to this day
is because of unemployment insurance.
- [Narrator] Some states are still paying
unemployment benefits
but in states that have stopped benefits,
Uber and Lyft are seeing drivers return,
and prices go down.
- Uber has said that they've
seen prices come down
in places like Miami, Houston and Atlanta.
Whereas big cities like New York,
San Francisco and LA,
prices are still high there
because drivers haven't returned.
- [Narrator] Uber said 90% of
the 90,000 inactive drivers
they surveyed in June indicated they plan
to return by September
when unemployment benefits
expire in most states.
Another factor keeping prices up,
ride share companies aren't just competing
for drivers amongst themselves,
they're also competing with
food delivery services,
which drivers say offer
safer work conditions.
- Traditionally, driving for hire
has always been a pretty dangerous job.
You really don't know who's getting
into your car at all times.
I think the CDC recommendation
was to stay six feet away from people,
and as soon as someone gets into your car,
they're breaking that rule.
So a lot of gig workers
have switched over to delivery services
and found that they liked it.
- Riders, on the other hand,
are back on the road in droves.
As rider demand as increased,
both Uber and Lyft
increased driver bonuses
earlier this year
to attract more drivers
back to the platform.
In April, Uber announced it
was allocating $250 million
in an effort to boost driver availability.
Lyft spent $572 million
on driver incentives
through the second quarter of 2021.
For now, these incentives
seem to be working.
According to Lyft, more drivers
are coming back to the
platform in recent months.
As drivers return to the roads,
Uber and Lyft hope that
prices will stabilize.
But they'll probably never be as cheap
as they typically were in the last decade.
There are a few reasons for this.
For one, Uber and Lyft
had begun phasing out discounts to riders,
even before the pandemic.
- What started happening
before the pandemic
is that pressure started
to build from investors.
Investors started saying you have
to have a sustainable model
to future profits.
- [Narrator] Uber and Lyft
had been using a subsidy model
since the very beginning,
and that model is fairly simple.
Startups raise venture capital,
and use those funds to attract customers
with deep discounts.
These subsidies could come in many forms,
from low shipping rates
for e-commerce sites
to coupons for free food delivery.
For ride hailing companies
like Uber and Lyft,
subsidies have involved attracting riders
with big discounts,
and then incentivizing drivers
to provide those rides.
But in recent years,
the companies have begun phasing
out those rider discount.
- They are not profitable companies.
They lose money nearly every year.
We don't know when they
will turn a net profit.
- [Narrator] For now, ride share companies
are still offering drivers incentives
as a way of making driving more attractive
for the long haul given
the ongoing challenges.
However, Uber said that
their driver numbers
have increased to a point
where they'll be pulling back
on driver incentives moving forward.
The company's near-term challenge
is keeping drivers after that.
- The bonus pay every single week
might be 30% of a driver's pay,
so you could imagine
that if they completely got
rid of these bonuses one day
and drivers saw their pay cut by 30%,
you'd have a huge exodus of drivers
at a time where the companies
are already struggling to match supply
and match demand.
- [Narrator] So companies are thinking
of new ways to make
driving more attractive.
- One of the things that Uber began doing
is that it started offering
free online language classes for drivers.
The company says a lot of
their drivers are immigrants.
English is not their first language,
so this could be a tool
that they could use to move up the ladder
and develop new skills.
- [Narrator] Also adding
to the cost of rides,
when regulatory changes like Prop 22
went into effect in late 2020,
companies shifted some
of the financial burden to customers.
- If consumers want better
benefits to drivers,
then we should also be willing
to pay slightly more.
- [Narrator] Both Uber
and Lyft are focusing more
on long-term profits.
Analysts say consumers should expect
to pay more per ride compared
to the discounted rates
before the pandemic.
- I think that they probably
weren't paying the full cost
of the fare in a lot of these situations
and kind of getting a good deal.
Riders may have to pay a little bit more
for their rides, and they may not like it
but hopefully, they'll
fine solace in the fact
that drivers are getting
part of that ride.
- [Narrator] For consumers,
ride share prices probably
will not stay at their current heights.
However, you probably won't see
those low subsidized
prices again any time soon.